mayor Giuliani thank you very much for
speaking to Sky News
what's the president's mood right now
are you on a victory lap or there's
another round of battle well I think
first of all there's there is a degree
of satisfaction that he's been
vindicated on the thing that started all
this I mean let's you know you talk
about other thing for this is all this
all began as an allegation the present
United States was conspiring with the
Russians to interfere in the 2016
election I knew that was false he knew
it was false we I believe it's a
political creation a frame-up that was
created by people to try to get him out
of office but there are no it's on there
as you know that Robert mullahs team and
not satisfied with the way that the
Attorney General concluded and that the
issue is around obstruction of justice
and they believe that their conclusion
was a lot more damaging do you accept
that that could be the case I accept
that they're a bunch of unethical slimy
prosecutors who are part of the Hillary
Clinton love machine and the hate Donald
Trump machine imagine leaking something
like that if you're a prosecutor imagine
how unethical you are you're supposed to
not leak when you're a prosecutor but on
the one hand you are denigrating Robert
mallas team but you're also applauding
their conclusion so which is it well
I'll tell you isn't it better when
you're cleared and more effective if
you're cleared by a group people hate
you
even they couldn't find or manufacture
evidence against him boy they tried this
were a group that's one of a group of
people have a pro Trump whatever people
are neutral these are people who
politically hate Donald Trump just read
Peter strux emails does Robert Muller
hate Donald Trump I don't know about
Robert MOA but he sure picked a heck of
biased people I mean they they didn't
have an open mind about Donald Trump yet
they couldn't find a stitch of evidence
of collusion and they can't point to one
fact about obstruction instead they say
oh it was far more damaging okay if
you're a good reporter first question
I'd be asked because I'm not given the
protection Democrats are given
first question IVF I said that it's give
me an example I'm not gonna listen to
that garbage give me an example of
what's more damaging in that report that
that bar covered up no examples let's
talk about Michael Cohen Donald Trump's
former lawyer he now says that he has 40
million files that could prove
conspiracy to collude with Russia he
might have some no I'm not worried about
kind of like the biggest liar that we've
seen in the last four or five years I
mean actually what Congress should be
doing if they are honest is be
recommending him for perjury prosecution
he went before chairman Cummings
chairman Cummings looked at of him and
said if you you lied
many many times if you lie now after you
cooperated I'm going to throw the book
at you
well then he said under oath I never
asked for a job there were at least 20
people that could be produced where he
asked for a job in the Trump
administration including yours truly why
is it that the president has had such
close relationships with these kinds of
people you look at Michael Cohen Paul
Manafort two men sentence is he just a
bad judge of character no he's a very
good judge of character
he has very very good people working for
him for really honorable terrific people
look at this cabinet look at the
Secretary of State the Secretary of
Defense people leave him as well well
sort of every president so does every
president it's impossible in the in the
high-level business world or in politics
that you don't have some people to
disappoint you I had it happen to me
when I was mayor and I can tell you I
never did anything dishonest I was
entirely ethical and I wanted an honest
administration one of the things to have
emerged during this Russia investigation
is the hush payments made by the
President to the former porn star stormy
Daniels does he regret those payments
now I don't know if that's relevant he
regrets them or not that those are very
normal things that have done in settling
cases I mean you you used the word hush
payment settlement he's settling a case
when a non-disclosure agreement and
corporations that people do it all the
time even for
cases where their false claims sounds
hot it sounds difficult people
understand but I asked the mayor not had
to do that for the city so he heard it
again if he had well I don't know if
you'd do it again or not but the person
is making an allegation that's untrue
that will have a significant effect on
your family your wife that you were
involved in some kind of an affair with
her and you pay her you you pay her to
drop the case or not bring the case and
then you sign a nondisclosure agreement
and the amount of money tells me they
were false claims because I settled
those cases or seen them settled for
millions and millions of dollars just
take a look in the newspapers and look
up some of these scandals what have your
recent conversations being like with the
president well there's no doubt the day
after we went to see him the night that
the report was released and he
congratulated he brought all the lawyers
over and he took pictures of every
single one including some of the younger
ones that wouldn't get a chance to
really interact with the president and
then the next day he asked Jay and I to
go over for lunch and he said you know I
didn't realize it but I feel like
there's been a burden lifted from my
shoulder and I kind of knew what he
meant I mean it's a it's a terrible
burden whether you're the president just
an ordinary human being whoever you are
to be suspected of and investigated for
something you didn't do and the
frustration is tremendous like I didn't
do it what are them what but they're
making that up I didn't do that I didn't
collude with Russians whatever it means
I don't know much since I didn't talk to
any Russians you were with me Rudy you
say you were with me for four months
did I ever talk to a Russian nobody
never took to Russian he felt a bit
powerless he felt it he felt maybe for
the first time in his life like he was a
victim you know and and and also
realizing do you think it hurt him the
most for all the people that they
brought into the investigation people
who they made bankrupt in let's talk
about Joe Biden he's been accused of
inappropriately touching a number of
women the president this week tweeted a
video mocking him do you think that's
appropriate from a man who himself has
been accused of sexual misconduct by a
number of women so there was a joke
I mean I don't know maybe you know there
are no jokes anymore
all right look at risky bill is they
from Donald Trump and enrich some people
would say well I think the whole thing
would with Biden is a Democrat Party
issue it's not for us I can't make out
what this is all about I see I see he
did that a lot on the other hand
everything I've seen I probably seen men
and good fate I mean I come from an
Italian family they hug all the time so
I'm not I'm not unused to men hugging
each other man hugging a woman some of
them were offended by it but none of
them thought of a sexual you're his
legal defense at the face of ethical
defense what is his weakness
what's his greatest weakness because we
all have them he's probably sometimes
too reluctant to fire people believe it
or not he's a much client he's he's
never given the benefit of this big and
maybe because he's not a politician he
doesn't show it as much as some power
he's actually a very kind man I mean he
he probably keeps some people around
that he shouldn't because he feels sorry
for him I have people that say to me oh
he's not gonna run for reelection
because he doesn't like the job they
don't know him
he loves the job he loves being
president he's getting better and better
at it and he accomplished a great deal
under the terrible burden of this
investigation I mean other presidents
have been crushed by things like this
become very depressed become very very
swollen
if anything it kind of spurred him to
maybe even do better